et sitôt les opérations terminées jean
louis debré le ministre de l'intérieur a
réuni la presse place beauvau pour
expliquer le choix du gouvernement
le moment était venu d'appliquer la loi
avec fermeté
mais avec le souci d'humanité et de
coeur que souhaite le gouvernement
que va-t-il se passer maintenant
pour la première catégorie
celle des
régularisables ils recevront un titre de
séjour et ceci dès la semaine prochaine
pour les personnes de la 2e et 3e
catégories
et qui ne sont pas régularisable et pour
lesquels il existe dès maintenant
des arrêtés de reconduite
exécutoire
cette reconduite sera mise en oeuvre
pour les autres c'est à dire pour ceux
qui ne sont pas régularisable mais pour
qui les procédures ne permette pas
encore aujourd'hui
de leur imposer de quitter le territoire
national
ces procédures seront conduites à leur
terme et ils devront quitter notre pays
tôt ou tard